anyone living her life who would I go
with you know I would love to go to
dinner with sergey koroliov who was the
father of the Soviet space program I
would also love to go to dinner with
someone who was recently passed just a
month ago his name was 10 Sri essen and
he was the father of the Chinese space
program and prob because he started the
whole thing you know he was acknowledged
as the the guy who made the first
practical rocket to go into space he's
the one that launched Yuri Gagarin in
the space and chin because he has an
interesting history he was actually in
the United States he studied in the
United States and MIT and Caltech and he
was a protege of theodore von Carmen's
Caltech and helped start the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory there and then he
got caught up in the anti-communism wave
and was accused of being a spy and was
actually deported back to China where he
built from nothing their entire missile
and space program you know so in a way
the very real way the United States and
trying to protect so-called protect our
secrets and getting you know throwing
this guy out of the country we helped
seed and start the Chinese missile
program both of those guys be very
interesting to meet and talk to